hey guys how's it going so today we are
going to be unboxing a Mavic tray and
you might be wondering do I need this
probably not but it's really cool bunch
of ye there is places which you couldn't
slide because it's like national parks
this guy whatever reason and it would be
so cool I thought to have a little
monitor to be able to see what I'm doing
well guess what they've got this thing
you've got a little place you can put
your magic get little handles and even a
little mount to put your eyes on let's
open this up and take a peek out full
amount up to iPhone 7 plus the basket
let's cut this tiny piece of tape with
this excessively large knife oh here's a
little mount and it can adjust sizes for
your phone I mean this is super simple
but it's pretty cool of course you don't
need to get this if you wanna use the
sort of ISO steadicam but this allows
you to do a lot more not your phones are
able to see what you're shooting whoo
I'm excited about this so something a
lot of people don't even realize is that
you can put your magic pro into Wi-Fi
mode and you don't need to use a
controller so the Wi-Fi it can be
enabled right here there's a little
switch you just scoot that over to Wi-Fi
through this in just like so a little
cushion here this little plastic area
you can just smash this thing right onto
your mattock and get a nice tight fit
just looks like one of those little
things that you can take in the water
they're called co-op yes okay Wi-Fi is
on
it is cool this is actually really cool
[Music]
I'm using three steady go figure
looks like I'd be great for you okay so
I chose for this outside the one thing
that I will probably have to adjust as I
play with it more is the autofocus curve
actually didn't have the autofocus on so
so one of the things with this is you do
have to press where you want things to
focus sometimes it does glass focus I'm
actually quite surprised I think this is
pretty cool I don't think it's gonna be
something that I would use every day but
I love knowing that this is an option
because there are those times that I'll
have my drone and I'm not able to
actually fly it so at least I'll be able
to get some super cool steady shots
without having to get any type of a
Steadicam or Ronin or anything I mean
this is just a super small little
solution and I think will work for you
buy one now is make sure you know your
Wi-Fi password before you get this thing
all geared up well thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this this is pretty cool I'm
super into it and I definitely plan on
juicing this in the future
this is made by polar Pro it's called to
Thomas Mavic tray they also make nd
filters and I have some cinematic and my
phantom 4 advanced so I'm going to try
those out and I will give you guys the
full review on those in the future so
stay tuned I will see you soon
bye
I'm interested by
[Music]